angela merkel looks friendly yet aloof
while rajab type era dawn anxiously
peers at the plummeting lira
that's how cartoonist enjoy a [ __ ]
portrays the turkish president's visit
to Germany he says turkey's currency
crisis is a huge problem for ad 1 it's
affecting everyone in the country he's
had to reduce the size of his satirical
magazine LeMans because the price of
paper has more than doubled in the last
few months
genetic dedication and self-sacrifice
have always been a part of likely in
Turkey especially in our field but now
it has become a real struggle to survive
and I don't know if we'll be able to
make it many Turks complain about the
rising cost of living
due to the currency crash and they worry
about the future some are hoping Germany
and the EU might step in they should
help us we don't have a problem with
Germany or the Germans Germany is our
oldest friend Turkey shouldn't have
gotten into this situation in the first
place I hope everything improves and
Germans depend on each other last year
relations between Turkey and Germany hit
an all-time low
pro-government Turkish newspapers
repeatedly around front pages
criticizing and even personally
insulting Chancellor Merkel accusing her
of Nazi practices
now it seems the Turkish government is
looking for a fresh start
Turkey's former u affairs minister
Eggman Bosch is among those who want
relations to improve the war in Syria
the unpredictable US president and the
currency crisis provide plenty of
reasons for Turkey and Germany to work
together he says this is his wish list
for the mackel adwin meeting more
understanding from Chancellor Merkel to
Turkey sensitivities cooperation with
Turkey in the fight against terror more
business cooperation and to be more
optimistic about Turkey's European
prospects and what can Chancellor Merkel
expect from president add one she can
expect from Turkey true friendship
through cooperation and everyone who
knows present-day Iran would agree that
if he makes a promise he keeps it so if
she can convince him to make some
promises in exchange of the promises
that she will make of course then she
knows she will be delivered cartoonist
enjoy a [ __ ] will be watching The Mikado
and meeting closely at the very least he
says it should serve up enough material
for some fresh satire